meine Damen und
[Musik]
Herren ich darf euch heute willkommen
heißen meinem letzten
Mal ich spiele heute zum letzten Mal
clash of Clans vor und einer Woche habe
ich das zweite Video der dreiteiligen
clash of Clans Serie im Rahmen vom Clash
von Nature hier auf meinem YouTube-Kanal
hochgeladen da geht's ja um eine riesige
Spendenaktion man kann 100000 € gewinnen
und der Youtuber der auf Platz eins ist
von allen teilnehmenden influencern
kriegt für seine Community sogar noch
ein Tesla da habe ich euch gesagt e gebt
Gas wir müssen es schaffen in Clash for
nature an trimax vorbeizuziehen der auf
der ein ist völlig normal dieser Typ lit
jeden Tag 30 Sonderangebot erhalten habe
ich gerade ein Sonderangebot
gekauft in meinem letzten Video zum
Clash V nature in clash of Clans war ich
auf Platz 12 und meine Damen und Herren
wir schauen jetzt mal nach auf welchem
Platz ich jetzt aktuell bin trimax auf
der 1 Papa Platte auf der 2 die kenne
ich alle nicht kenne ich alle nicht wir
s wir
wir wir sind auf 21 hier sind
runtergerutscht was seid denn ihr für
eine Community und der aktuelle
Zwischenstand ist auch nicht so super
ich RAS komplett aus so oder so meine
Damen und Herren würde ich sagen gehen
wir in den Angriff denn dadurch dass man
Leute angreift und dadurch halt Gold und
Elixier sammelt macht man das alles auch
für den Clash V nature deswegen gehen
wir jetzt einfach mal drauf und meem
letzten Video hab einige geschrieben du
gehst komplett dumm vor mein allerbestes
so oder so geht der Kampf los wir müssen
natürlich schauen wo wir als erstes
drauf gehen das hier sind so flugsachen
deswegen können wir die am besten vom
Boden aus angreifen da setze ich mal
hier die Dings
drauf dann würde ich sagen machen wir
hier vorne das ist hier eine Dings
Abwehr da setzen wir einfach mal zwei
Ballons hin generell können wir hier
vorne jetzt auch noch mal eben kurz die
Riesen hinpacken so dass unsere Leute
mit den Bomben nicht gesehen werden
Angriff
[Musik]
er warum geht auf die Kaserne da
rechts
ochch Mann jetzt habe ich nur 98 und zwe
Steine weil kein auf diese Kaserne da
rechts gegangen ist dadurch dass ich
jetzt Gold und Elixier gesammelt habe
kommt das alles in unseren riesen Pot
rein und da müssen wir wirklich an dem
anderen Team vorbeiziehen meine fünf
Bauarbeiter sind gerade beschäftig das
seht ihr ja dann z.B auch hier ran dass
er hier gerade ein bisschen was baut
guck mal die sehen alle aus wie Sandra
hier mit Hammer Uga Uga musste Haus
bauen die hat der zu Hause aktuellen
Radlader bei sich im Vorgarten stehen
weil da auch wieder irgendein Projekt
hat ich glaube ich brauche nicht noch
mal erwähnen dass man mit mehr Bauhütten
einfach schneller voranommt im Spiel ihr
müsst nichts kaufen bei clash of Clans
um Gott das ganze Spiel ist kostenlos so
kommt man allerdings natürlich ein
bisschen schneller voran ich habe
natürlich schon die maximale Anzahl
erreicht fünf Stück ne seht ihr hier
zack Bauhütte 1 Bauhütte 2 Bauhütte 3
Bauhütte 4
[Musik]
und Bauhütte
5 Schub für Bauarbeiter
eine Stunde lang
das Sandra was h ich für ein Turo
aktiviert halt Maul und ihr seht do
schon hier dass unser Clan echt sehr
sehr aktiv ist also die schreiben hier
die ganze Zeit das ist sehr sehr geil
und ihr könnt auch mal sehen wenn ich
jetzt hier Verstärkung Anfrage nee
falsch wenn ich
hier wenn ich hier Verstärkung anfordere
und auf Senden klicke seht ihr schon wie
schnell ich jetzt überhaupt erstmal was
bekomme
da Level 2 Level 2 Walküre bist du blöd
GB mir doch was Gutes da Level 5 Ballon
danke das ist mein Clan wenn ihr Bock
habt kommt rein wenn nicht seid ihr halt
loser wenn ihr meinem Team se beitretet
Freunde bekommt ihr übrigens auch so ein
kleines
dekoändchen mega süß Problem ist das
ganze geht nur noch bis zum 11 Dezember
das heiß gib das ladet euchans runter
geht Kämpfen im Spiel nicht in echt in
real life ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft
und sammelt Gold und Elixier das ist
alles für ein guten Zweck ich glaub den
Tesla kriegen wir eh nicht mehr ich
gönne das trimax hier so oder so würde
ich sagen ich bilde ein paar Truppen aus
ich wollte das schon immer mal machen
ich habe eine Armee Verfügbarkeit bei
einem Angriff von 140 deswegen hole ich
mir jetzt nur riesen ich werde jetzt
einen Angriff mit 28 riesen machen wir
haben zwei Möglichkeiten alles auf einen
Haufen oder
nicht alles auf ein Haufen wenn eine
Falle kommt mir egal eine riesenbombe
wird uns jetzt richtig auf jeden Fall
den Arsch versolen ich setze hier vorne
jetzt auch noch mal das Ding hin dann
kommen noch mal irgendwie Walküren und
irgendwelche Bogenschützen und die
Ballons aber jetzt kommen erstmal meine
riesen 20 riesen oder wie viel hat ich
mir geholt kann ja rechnen nee
mehr 24 riesen glaube ich oder ich weiß
nicht ist auch egal die geben auf jeden
Fall ordentlich Gas guck mal die haben
schon was schon weg sind schon bei 21
ich nur noch mit riesen an alter was
machen die denn für ein hackmack da die
zerstören ja alles
ich bin bei 26% 29% bin ich 31% 34% wie
schnell geht denn
[Applaus]
das
Nein schon wieder so close schreib jetzt
mal einfach den Leuten in meinem Clan
sagt mal einen Witz für mein Video bin
mal gespannt was dabei rumkommt fragt
kannst du mein Dorf schlagen mit Ansage
ich kann sein Dorf schlagen nur mit ihm
mit einem Barbaren ab in den Angriff
mein kleiner Barbar und wo starten wir
hier du schaffst das
zumindest das war wohl nichts meine
Damen und Herren allerdings haben die
Leute in meinem Clan einige Witze
reingeschrieben treffen sich zwei blinde
schön dich zu
sehen ma wir weiter mit dem nächsten
Witz warum klaut Robin Hood Deo er
wollte es unter den Armen
treffen sich zwei Eier warum bist du so
behaart darauf dass andere klappe ich
bin eine
Kiwi ist echt der beschissenste Clan den
es gibt so oder so würde ich sagen
machen wir zu guter letzt noch mal einen
Angriff mit einer normalen Truppe
sammeln dementsprechend natürlich ein
bisschen was für den Clash V nature ein
guten Swag guten Swag oh mein Gott ist
peinlich als wir gehen natürlich normal
vor hier vorne das Ding kann uns nicht
angreifench dass die jetzt fokussiert
sind auf den Riesen können wir hier ganz
easy das Ding zerstören hier vorne das
greift uns auch nicht an weil es ist
eine luftabweh da setzt man ah da ist
aber eine Kanone das heißt wir setzen
ihn hierhin und den Riesen vielleicht
hier vorne Kanone geht da vorne auf den
Magier drauf dementsprechend gehen wir
jetzt erstmal hier die kann uns nämlich
nichts haben das ist ein Dings das kann
uns auch nichts haben dann geht der hier
vorne drauf dass der Magier darauf
konzentriert der Luftballon kann da sein
Ding machen h brauchen aber auf jeden
Fall drei riesen weil hier vorne noch
das Teil kommt kann ich hier hinsetzen
nee das geht leider nicht dann hau ich
hier vorne natürlich den Typen hin der
das einfach kaputt macht mit seiner
Bombe der geht hier rüber hier hauen wir
noch mal ein Kollegen hin der da die
Mauer kaputt macht und dann kommt er
hier hin der auf die Kanone geht das
sollte der auch alleine schaffen meiner
Ansicht nach hier vorne setze ich dann
mal weil wir da jetzt hier ein paar
Truppen haben noch mal eben kurz hier
die heiligen Frau hin ich habe den Namen
G gerade kurz vergessen immer wenn die
Schaden macht werden die ander dann auf
jeden Fall geheilt bzw sie halilt
einfach direkt die ganzen Leute und das
packen the final Countdown meine Damen
und Herren wir haben nur noch das
Armeelager hier vorne und das ist jetzt
auch Geschichte wir haben ein perfekten
100% Sieg eingefahren so oder so wird
das alles gesammelt und kommt in unser
Ranking gegen Team trees beim Clash for
nature deswegen meine Damen und Herren
bis zum 11 dezember um 9 Uhr könnt ihr
noch dran teilnehmen gebt Gas und Tesla
werden wir nicht mehr kriegen für unser
Community aber vielleicht werden wir
Team noch überholen so oder so wie das
ganze Geld eh gespendet ist eine sehr
coole Aktion Danke schön an supercell
und clash of Clans dass ich da ganze bei
der ganzen Sache mit am Start war mir
sehr sehr viel Freude bereitet wenn euch
das Video hier gefallen hat und
eventuell doch noch mal mehr Cash of
Clans sehen wollt dann lasst auf jeden
Fall einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert diesen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich habe so hunger
ich gehe jetzt was essen und ich habe
richtig Bock auf so ein Ferkel was die
hier immer überin Grill grillen